what's going on guys
here at screen junkies we always try to
fight the good fight we've tried to fix
franchises that were broken
diehard Robocop and Man of Steel and our
resident fixer Nick Mundy has fought
these battles with quivering rage but
he's here today to fight a battle I'm
not exactly sure needs to be fought how
to fix Marvel Nick look first off I'm
not trying to be a dick here
I love the Marvel movies I love them I
haven't loved Iron Man - but some cracks
in the armor are starting to appear
there cracks in the armor Hal cracks
okay but part of me thinks that you're
doing this preemptively it's like you're
in a relationship and you're being like
I'm gonna break up with you before you
can break up with me ha I win but now
I'm alone you're right so here's the
first step to fix a Marvel Cinematic
Universe so he'll I have a question for
you and the audience at large sure uh
how excited were you when they announced
agents of shield pretty pumped yeah I'm
for that me too how excited were you
after you watch the first episode I
started to hedge a little bit now and
then the third episode I have not seen
all of them see when I watch it it feels
like unauthorized fanfiction cosplay
that was uploaded - I film in 2002 hmm
and then it's like try not to get too
many views before the Disney lawyers
swooped in and shut it down for
copyright infringement
it's like Marvel you've already
established that superheroes exists in
this show so it's not far-fetched for
the audience to believe that superheroes
could be in this show you're making a
pretty decent point this is kind of like
if they made a new Star Wars movie it's
like no we Rock opening Darth Vader
we're not gonna put in Skywalker Han
Solo we're gonna put in just the bridge
of the deaths
exactly exactly they had a Thor
crossover without four and it took place
after the movie happened the door
crossover was them cleaning up from
those that happened in Thor you know
when I saw the Avengers you know what I
was like you know what I really want to
see what happens to the people picking
up all the garbage off man I want a show
on Tuesdays on ABC at 8:00
I would rather watch Smallville I much
rather watch Smallville
I'd rather watch the old flash TV show
what about Lois and Clark get better
bad guys well you got Loki No Loki's
great who else you have the Mandarin oh
yeah here's the problem you have Loki
and then that's it there's not one
memorable bad guy outside of Loki in the
movies and you need that if you want
this cinematic universe to continue to
grow and crossover because otherwise
it's just like hey let's just get Loki
because you know KITT I have no idea who
the bad guy in Thor 2 was Malekith you
have a lousier bauer uh was he about
ultimately who who was a bad guy in that
movie actually gonna say Loki's more of
an antihero after that last Thor okay so
Marvel took the only villain that they
had in the entire universe and kind of
made him like the cool like leather
jacket gag yet everyone likes yes like
CM Punk of Marvel and now we don't have
a bad guy
Thanos is probably gonna show up with a
cigarette and a Harley he wants get the
Infinity Gauntlet and a party at Fort
Lauderdale because all the bad guys got
to be cool and having fun number three
oh god make the end credits meaningful
again the end of Iron Man 3 yeah was
just Robert Downey jr. and Mark Ruffalo
doing a bit Thor was Natalie Portman and
Thor making out but there was the
guardians of the galaxy one in between
I'm talk about the end credits there was
a middle nugget no that wasn't but about
the scene there's Oh Laura two nuggets
the one that's important to the
franchise and the future movies is in
the middle and then it's a fun thing at
the end but I still have to wait it's
2:45 in the morning you know and if I
had work which I don't because I'm a
grown man go into a comic book movie at
midnight I would be really tired so the
least they can do is if they're gonna
put a scene at the end of it make it
meaningful so it doesn't interfere with
your hypothetical job yes what you're
doing is that to me right now that's the
definition of nitpicking you want to
game-changers scene
within the credits I like a fun moment
at the end ok fine put that in the
middle of the credits and then put the
real thing at the end of the credits
then you're gonna be like kind of
underwhelmed in the middle and then
you're good ok like that was a tasty
morsel oh I can't wait for the main
treat
what kind of dandy are you when you see
this with a little is a tasty morsel you
sounded like a cartoon cat about to eat
a fish now that was a tasty morsel
all right what's your next point Nick
let me ask you a question how great
would have been during the Avengers if
spider-man Human Torch and Wolverine
showed up that would've been pretty
sweet yeah yeah the problem is like all
the rights to all these Marvel
characters are at different studios like
Fox owns the x-men and Fantastic Four
Sony own spider-man those studios
obviously don't do not know what they're
doing
Marvel if they got the rights back would
make both spider-man and x-men great
then they could combine the universes to
make one badass 9 hour movie I help
Galactus is here King [ __ ] up let's call
the Avengers x-men and spiders
to save the day that's what I want us
yeah I don't have a problem whoa I don't
have a problem with the state of the
x-men like there's a movie coming out
that I'm excited for are you spider-man
have you seen the pictures hey video
guys show the pictures of what this guy
looks like quick sit heavy quicksilver's
do we need okay come on look at your
what I'm gonna hedge my like steampunk
characters oh it looks great it looks
like a character from Boogie Nights
maybe you're right maybe the new x-men
movie is gonna be good maybe the new
spider-man is gonna be good maybe but
Louis action looks off the charts okay
maybe but what would you rather see a
good x-men and spider-man movie that
surprises you that it's not a piece of
or the best movie ever made
I'd like the best movie ever made but
it's not a layup that you're gonna put
all of those characters and together and
it's going to be perfect and let me also
say this say what you will about Marvel
there's still miles ahead of DC yeah and
you know here this is the most screwed
up part about the whole thing you know
what have been better than the Avengers
the Justice League
but now Marvel has been so good for so
many years and they make it look easy
that DC has to play catch-up and then
force the Justice League down our
throats
that's probably gonna be just pure I'm
still holding out hope that Justice
League could be good but it does seem a
little bit like oh we got to catch up
for my job we gotta catch up because you
know oh my god they're making another
good movie they're making a good movie
they're making a movie about a fin
raccoon and we can't
do Wonder Woman huh well set Nick
so did you agree with Nick Mundy did you
disagree vehemently leave an answer in
the comments section below let us know
the best answer is gonna get a screen
junkies t-shirt and by the way we really
do give away these t-shirts have we sent
you a t-shirt in the past tweet us a
picture of you in the t-shirt we gave
you something for free the least you can
do is send us a picture thank you and
let people know that it's not a myth or
an urban legend about these t-shirts
they are very real I want to thank my
good friend Nick Mundy Nick thank you to
being here and if you want me to fix
something put in your comments okay
and they leave the Astros out of it
thanks for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit
me up on Twitter I like James Avery who
a lot of us know as Uncle Phil from The
Fresh Prince of Bel Air
he was also the voice of the shredder
but you may call me the shredder